would you eat this avocado about this
one they're actually the same just one's
been sitting out for a few hours and
sure one doesn't look as good but that
doesn't mean you should just throw it
out in 1989 the average American ate
about one pound of avocados a year by
2017 that amount had increased Sevenfold
but as much as we like to eat them the
struggle with Browning avocados is real
some people might try to prevent it by
putting the avocado pit in the bowl but
it does not work that way
just like with apples bananas and
potatoes the flesh of an avocado Browns
when it's exposed to oxygen in the air
it's a process called oxidation and it
happens when the oxygen reacts with
compounds called polyphenols with the
help of enzymes called polyphenol
oxidase this damages the tissue of the
flesh in the process turning it Brown
but the brown color is not a sign that
it's spoiling you'd have to leave it out
for a few days before it spoiled from
oxidation that brown color is actually
from a non-toxic chemical called melanin
it shows up in everything from fruit to
the iris in your eyes
needless to say that bowl of brown
avocado won't hurt you however the more
oxidation that takes place the more
tissues it damages for example bruising
or chilling an avocado for too long can
lead to significant oxidation which
actually damages so much tissue that it
changes the texture and flavor of the
fruit so that it's mushy and bitter but
a little browning won't make a
difference
to prove it we did an experiment we
served green avocados and avocados that
were left to brown for a few hours
tastes like a normal of akkad oh I think
I don't like that one I don't know what
I was like it tastes a little bad pretty
strong taste I would say pretty strong
avocado earthy taste but yeah it tastes
very ripe yeah
pretty standard avocado it tastes like a
regular avocado but rotten why did you
feed me a rotten avocado I really that
one actually tastes a little bit better
oh oh there's one doesn't taste rotten
so that's good okay that is much more
right super mushy yeah the one kind of
just tasted like wet paper this one
actually tasted like something this
one's fine I like it enough it's an
avocado they taste the same other than
one tasted older that's the first one
the first one tasted older I was like
sour and the second one tasted like a
regular avocado how fast your avocado
browns depends on the environment like
how much oxygen is in the air what the
temperature is and how acidic it is
warmer temperatures accelerate the
chemical reaction turning your avocado
Brown faster but if you squirt some
citrus on the top the acidity prevents
oxidation and you can keep it looking
fresher for longer either way even
though we couldn't agree on which tasted
better
both were perfectly edible so next time
you have some old avocado don't just
throw it out and if the unsightly Brown
ruins your appetite just give it a quick
stir and voila